From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
来自芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
All right, you're turning your laptop so we can both look?
好了，你把笔记本电脑转过来，这样我们俩都能看吗？
Turning the laptop, so that we can both watch this.
把笔记本电脑转过来，这样我们俩就能看这个了。
That's my co-worker, Emanuele Berry, standing up to show me a clip from an old film on her computer. This is something that she's shown lots of people since she first saw it. It's from an old Soviet movie from 1936.
那是我的同事伊曼纽尔·贝里，她站起来给我展示她电脑里一部老电影的片段。这是她第一次看到之后就向很多人展示过的东西。它出自1936年的一部苏联老电影。
OK, so this is a film called, The Circus. It's kind of like the Russian version of It's a Wonderful Life. It's that classic black and white movie that comes on TV all the time, that's heartwarming, that everybody knows. But then when I saw what was happening, I was like, what is happening? Um, yeah, I'm going to hit Play.
好的，这是一部名为《马戏团》的电影。它有点像俄罗斯版的《生活多美好》。那是一部电视上经常播放的经典黑白电影，非常温馨，每个人都知道。但当我看到正在发生的事情时，我想，这到底是怎么回事？嗯，是的，我要点播放了。
OK.
好的。
[SINGING IN NON-ENGLISH]
[非英语歌曲]
So there's this beautiful blonde woman. She's singing in the center of the circus tent. She's an American who has come to Russia to perform. And then this man just starts screaming, stop the show, stop the show.
所以这里有一位美丽的金发女郎。她在马戏团帐篷的中央唱歌。她是一个来到俄罗斯表演的美国人。然后这个男人就开始尖叫，停止表演，停止表演。
[NON-ENGLISH]
[非英语]
So let me explain who he is. He's German. To be honest, he looks a little like Hitler-- the mustache, or whatever.
让我来解释一下他是谁。他是德国人。老实说，他看起来有点像希特勒——那胡子，或者其他什么东西。
Oh, and it's 1936, so Hitler's on the rise.
哦，那是1936年，所以希特勒正在崛起。
Yes. And he's in love with this American circus star, but she's rejected him. And so to get revenge, he is going to reveal her secret to the world, the secret that she's been keeping throughout the entire film. And then he brings out this Black baby.
是的。他爱上了这位美国马戏明星，但她拒绝了他。为了报复，他打算向全世界揭露她的秘密，那个她在整部电影中一直保守的秘密。然后他带出了一个黑人婴儿。
[NON-ENGLISH]
[非英语]
Then the baby's, like, a toddler size.
那是婴儿，大概是幼儿大小。
Yeah, maybe two. And then the German, he runs up the stairs, and he holds the baby up, almost like Simba. And he starts shaking the baby and screaming, she slept with a Negro.
是的，大概两岁吧。然后那个德国人跑上楼梯，把婴儿举起来，就像《狮子王》里的辛巴一样。他开始摇晃婴儿并尖叫，她和一个黑人睡了。
[NON-ENGLISH]
[非英语]
She gave birth to a Black child.
她生下了一个黑人孩子。
You're reading the subtitles?
你在读字幕吗？
Now, he's shaking this child over and over again. He's like, a Black child, a Black child.
现在，他一遍又一遍地摇晃这个孩子。他说，一个黑人孩子，一个黑人孩子。
[NON-ENGLISH]
[非英语]
And then this guy comes up to him, this Russian guy in the audience. And he's like, what's the problem? And the German guy says, it's a Black child. A white woman gave birth to a Black child.
然后这个家伙走到他面前，这个观众席里的俄罗斯人。他问，有什么问题吗？那个德国人说，这是一个黑人孩子。一个白人妇女竟然生下了一个黑人孩子。
And while the Russian guy just literally shrugged his shoulders.
而那个俄罗斯人只是耸了耸肩。
Yeah, he shrugged his shoulders. And he says, so what?
是的，他耸了耸肩。他说，那又怎样？
[NON-ENGLISH]
[非英语]
And the German guy goes off on this speech and puts the baby down. And the toddler, he just sort of walks off. And people in the audience, they sweep the baby up in their arms.
那个德国人开始发表长篇大论，并放下婴儿。那个幼儿只是走开了。观众席里的人们把孩子抱在怀里。
To protect the baby from this guy.
为了保护孩子不受那个家伙的伤害。
Yeah. And so they're passing this Black kid around, all of these white Russian folks.
是的。他们就在那里传递这个黑人孩子，所有这些白人俄罗斯人。
And they're laughing at the guy.
他们还在嘲笑那个家伙。
Yeah. He's like, why are you laughing? Why is this funny? Remember, it's 1936. In the US, we're more than 30 years before interracial marriage is legal everywhere.
是的。他问，你们为什么要笑？这有什么好笑的？记住，那是1936年。在美国，离种族间婚姻合法化还有30多年。
I mean, it's Jim Crow. Black people are still being lynched. And to see this scene where this guy is being told, by all these white people, mind you, you're crazy, this is no big deal, I'm like, what is happening here? And as I started to do more research, I learned that this was part of Soviet propaganda for decades-- this message, America is racist, WE are not.
我是说，那是种族隔离制度。黑人仍在被私刑处死。看到这一幕，在这个家伙被所有这些白人——请注意——告知“你疯了，这没什么大不了的”时，我想，这到底是怎么回事？随着我开始做更多的研究，我了解到这几十年来一直是苏联宣传的一部分——传达这样一个信息：美国是种族主义者，而我们不是。
In the 1920s and 1930s, African-Americans, they actually moved to the Soviet Union because it was promising a better life. The boy in the film, that Black baby, is actually the son of an African-American who moved to the Soviet Union in the 1930s.
在20世纪20年代和30年代，非裔美国人实际上搬到了苏联，因为它承诺了更好的生活。电影里的那个男孩，那个黑人婴儿，实际上是20世纪30年代移居苏联的一位非裔美国人的儿子。
Wow.
哇。
And I haven't gotten to the last bit of the scene, which is actually my favorite part of the whole thing. So this Russian woman is cradling the baby, rocking it back and forth. And then she starts singing to him.
我还没说到那个场景的最后一部分，这实际上是我整件事中最喜欢的部分。那个俄罗斯女人抱着婴儿，前后摇晃着他。然后她开始对他唱歌。
Mr. Dreams stepping soft, maketh he no noise. Yeah. So she's totally putting this baby to sleep.
睡梦先生轻声走过，不发出一点声响。是的。所以她完全是在哄这个婴儿睡觉。
Yeah, they're putting the baby to sleep. Yeah. And then she passes the baby to this next person. And it just becomes this thing where they're embracing this child, one from the next, rocking it back and forth and singing to it. The other thing that's happening in the scene is that they're all singing in different languages. The Soviet Union at this time, there are all these different ethnic groups.
是的，他们正在哄孩子睡觉。是的。然后她把孩子传给下一个人。这变成了一种互相拥抱这个孩子，一个接一个，前后摇晃并对他唱歌的情景。这个场景中发生的另一件事是，他们都用不同的语言唱歌。当时的苏联，有各种各样的不同民族。
And then there they are, all embracing this Black baby.
然后他们就在那里，都在拥抱这个黑人婴儿。
[SINGING IN NON-ENGLISH]
[非英语歌曲]
When I'm watching this Black baby being embraced, I wonder, was it true? Would Black people really be embraced like that? And for the--
当我看着这个黑人婴儿被拥抱时，我想，这是真的吗？黑人真的会被那样拥抱吗？对于——
In the Soviet Union?
在苏联？
In the Soviet Union. And for the African-Americans who went over there and left to escape racism, did they somehow actually escape racism? Because that's a question that I think about a lot. Can I go somewhere in the world and escape racism?
在苏联。对于那些为了逃避种族主义而去那里的非裔美国人来说，他们真的逃避了种族主义吗？因为这是一个我经常思考的问题。我能去世界上的某个地方逃避种族主义吗？
Yeah.
是的。
I had a year or two where I really thought about this a lot. I was working as a journalist in Ferguson, covering months of protests and a community-- really, I was covering a community that was in crisis after the shooting death of Michael Brown.
我有一两年时间真的在想这个问题。我当时在弗格森担任记者，报道了几个月的抗议活动，一个社区——我报道的是一个在迈克尔·布朗被枪杀后陷入危机的社区。
And I just had this experience where I felt like I'd just seen some of the worst parts of American racism, from watching people threaten other people because of the color of their skin, to just looking day after day at the social inequalities that exist in St. Louis and the structural things, like redlining. And it was kind of hopeless. I really felt kind of hopeless about it, at least at the time.
我有过这样的经历，我觉得我刚看到了美国种族主义最糟糕的一些部分，从看着人们因为肤色而威胁他人，到日复一日地审视圣路易斯存在的社会不平等和结构性问题，比如红线政策。这简直让人绝望。至少在当时，我真的感到绝望。
And I was a little bit like, I think I just have to leave here. I used to almost play this game as a coping mechanism where I would think about where in the world can I go? I would talk to my friends about Ghana, or Central America, or places in the Caribbean. I'm like, do you think it's better there? Would it be better there to be a Black person there?
我当时有点觉得，我想我必须离开这里。我曾经几乎把这当作一种应对机制，玩一个游戏，我想我能去世界上的什么地方？我会和朋友谈论加纳、中美洲或加勒比地区的一些地方。我在想，你觉得那里会更好吗？在那里做一个黑人会更好吗？
And so seeing this film made you wonder about Russia and, did it work out for the Black Americans who moved there?
所以看到这部电影让你对俄罗斯感到好奇，那些搬到那里的美国黑人后来过得怎么样？
I don't necessarily think that Russia is a better place to live as a Black person. But for those people who did move there in the 1930s, and their kids, and their grandkids, what role did race end up playing in their lives? How did it work out for them?
我不一定认为俄罗斯是一个作为黑人生活更好的地方。但是对于那些在20世纪30年代搬到那里的人，以及他们的孩子和孙辈，种族最终在他们的生活中扮演了什么角色？他们过得怎么样？
That's actually the thing that we're going to be talking about in general in today's program. We have stories of people who decide I'm going to go somewhere, I'm going to move there, I'm going to try to fit in. And we see what happens. And for Act One, an act we are calling Black in the USSR--
这实际上是我们今天要讨论的事情。我们有一些人决定，“我要去某个地方，我要搬到那里，我要尝试融入。”我们来看看发生了什么。对于第一幕，我们称之为“苏联的黑人”——
Aw, that's cheesy.
噢，那太老土了。
You came up with that name.
那个名字是你起的。
I know, but I was joking. [LAUGHS]
我知道，但我是在开玩笑。[笑]
But it's good. [LAUGHS] Anyway, for that act, Emanuele, you looked for descendants of those African-American expats in Russia, and just explain who you found.
但这很好。[笑] 不管怎样，对于那一幕，伊曼纽尔，你寻找了那些在俄罗斯的非裔美国外籍人士的后代，解释一下你找到了谁。
OK. So the woman that I found, her name is Yelena Khanga. And she wrote this book called Soul to Soul. She's a Black Russian, born and raised there. And I don't know, I sort of felt a connection to her the more I read about her, because she's a college athlete, like I was. She's a journalist, like I am. Her grandfather is from the same county in Mississippi that my grandmother is from.
好的。我找到的那个女人的名字叫叶莲娜·汉加。她写了一本名为《灵魂对灵魂》的书。她是一个黑人俄罗斯人，在那里出生长大。我不知道，随着我读到的关于她的内容越多，我越觉得与她有联系，因为她是一名大学运动员，就像我一样。她是一名记者，就像我一样。她的祖父来自密西西比州，和我祖母来自同一个县。
Wow.
哇。
And I don't know, I sort of just felt connected, in a way.
我不知道，我只是在某种程度上感到联系。
How did you find me?
你怎么找到我的？
Like, originally?
像，最初是怎么找到的？
Yeah.
是的。
Uh, your book.
呃，你的书。
Oh, you read the book, OK.
哦，你读过那本书，好的。
I read the book, yeah.
我读过那本书，是的。
So like I said, Yelena is a journalist. She had a successful talk show in Moscow. They call her the Russian Oprah, which is almost definitely because she's Black and had a talk show.
如我所说，叶莲娜是一名记者。她在莫斯科有一个成功的脱口秀节目。他们称她为“俄罗斯的奥普拉”，这几乎肯定是因为她是黑人并且有一个脱口秀。
It was her grandparents who moved to Russia back in the 1930s. They had a leftist New York version of a rom-com meet-cute. Her grandmother, Bertha, was a Polish Jew who'd been arrested at a women's rights demonstration. Her grandfather, Oliver Golden, was Black and had been arrested down the street at a human rights demonstration.
是她的祖父母在20世纪30年代搬到了俄罗斯。他们有一个左翼纽约版的浪漫喜剧式邂逅。她的祖母伯莎是一位波兰犹太人，在一次妇女权利示威中被捕。她的祖父奥利弗·戈登是黑人，在街那头的另一次人权示威中被捕。
And they met at the jail. And in the morning, the rabbi came to bail my grandmother out. And my grandmother said, oh, wonderful. Could you please bail me out together with my new friend, Oliver Golden.
他们在监狱里相遇了。早上，拉比来保释我祖母出去。我祖母说，噢，太好了。你能连同我的新朋友奥利弗·戈登一起保释我出去吗？
The rabbi, her father, saw that Oliver was Black.
拉比，也就是她的父亲，看到奥利弗是黑人。
And her father looked at her and said, well, you're staying in jail with your new friend, and left them there. And that's how their love story began.
她父亲看着她说，嗯，你就和你的新朋友留在监狱里吧，然后就把他们留在那里了。他们的爱情故事就是这样开始的。
That's a weird matchmaker situation.
那真是一个奇怪的媒人情况。
[CHUCKLES] But it worked.
[轻笑] 但它起作用了。
The couple didn't see a future for themselves in America, so they decided to go to the Soviet Union. Oliver had visited before, and they wanted to help build Lenin's great new society, one that promised no racism. Oliver and Bertha settled in Uzbekistan.
这对夫妇在美国看不到自己的未来，所以他们决定去苏联。奥利弗以前访问过那里，他们想帮助建设列宁伟大的新社会，一个承诺没有种族主义的社会。奥利弗和伯莎定居在乌兹别克斯坦。
My grandfather thought there would be some kind of a kinship between African-Americans and dark-skinned Uzbek people. That's why he chose to go there. And he worked as an expert in cotton.
我祖父认为非裔美国人和深色皮肤的乌兹别克人之间会有某种亲缘关系。这就是他选择去那里的原因。他是一名棉花专家。
Yes, her grandfather left the American South and traveled halfway around the world to work in cotton. He developed a new breed of cotton that would work for Uzbekistan's short growing season.
是的，她祖父离开美国南部，跋涉半个地球去从事棉花工作。他培育出了一种适合乌兹别克斯坦短暂生长季节的新品种棉花。
And life was good. They made good money, had a nice apartment, a nanny for when their daughter, Lily, was born in 1934. Oliver wanted her to have everything he thought white kids got in the United States, so Lily had language tutors, music and tennis lessons.
生活很美好。他们赚了不少钱，有漂亮的公寓，在1934年女儿莉莉出生时还有一个保姆。奥利弗希望她拥有他认为美国白人孩子得到的一切，所以莉莉有语言导师、音乐和网球课程。
But their lives got harder after they became full Soviet citizens and lost their foreigner status. And after Stalin began to solidify his power, they started to live like everybody else. Oliver died in 1940.
但当他们成为正式的苏联公民并失去了外国人身份后，他们的生活变得更加艰难。在斯大林开始巩固权力后，他们开始像其他人一样生活。奥利弗于1940年去世。
Lily grew up and went to college in Moscow. She married a politician from Zanzibar, Yelena's dad. He died shortly after Yelena's birth, so the only consistent Black presence in her life was her mom. The neighborhood she grew up in-- all white. From a very young age, being Black meant constantly explaining herself to the world.
莉莉长大后在莫斯科上了大学。她嫁给了一位来自桑给巴尔的政治家，也就是叶莲娜的父亲。他在叶莲娜出生后不久就去世了，所以她生活中唯一持续的黑人存在就是她的母亲。她长大的街区——全是白人。从很小的时候起，作为黑人意味着不断地向世界解释自己。
My best friend was Sasha. He was a neighbor. And since my childhood, I thought he was my brother, because we were together all the time. So in the street when somebody would ask me, why are you Black, he would say, number one, she's my sister. Number two, she is Black because her father was from Africa. And guess what? Everybody's Black in Africa.
我最好的朋友是萨沙。他是邻居。从童年起，我就认为他是我的哥哥，因为我们总是待在一起。所以当街上有人问我，为什么你是黑人，他会说，第一，她是我的妹妹。第二，她是黑人，因为她的父亲来自非洲。猜猜怎么着？非洲每个人都是黑人。
And they would say, yeah, but she was born in Moscow. She's supposed to be white. And he says, OK, Yelena, if somebody else asks you the question about color, we're just beating them right away. So we were known in the neighborhood as the most cruel fighter. He taught me how to fight. He told me, you take a bottle, you break the bottle, and with whatever is left, you just put in their face. So we were bad kids in the neighborhood.
他们会说，是啊，但她是在莫斯科出生的。她应该是白人。然后他说，好的，叶莲娜，如果还有人问你肤色的问题，我们就直接揍他们。所以我们在街区里被称为最残忍的打手。他教我如何打架。他告诉我，你拿一个瓶子，打破瓶子，然后用剩下的东西，直接戳在他们的脸上。所以我们是街区里的坏孩子。
This was when she was only seven years old. So Russia wasn't some racism-free utopia. People like Yelena obviously came up against what I would call racism. But when I asked Yelena about it--
那是她才七岁的时候。所以俄罗斯并不是什么没有种族主义的乌托邦。像叶莲娜这样的人显然遇到了我会称之为种族主义的东西。但当我问叶莲娜这件事时——
That was not racism. That was curiosity. That was ignorance, but not racism.
那不是种族主义。那是好奇心。那是无知，但不是种族主义。
This happened a lot in our conversation. Yelena would tell a story about some experience that sounded honestly horrible to me, but she'd always insist that it wasn't racism or discrimination. It was ignorance.
这种情况在我们的谈话中发生过很多次。叶莲娜会讲一些对我来说真的听起来很可怕的经历，但她总是坚持认为那不是种族主义或歧视。那是无知。
I think that ignorance can be, and often is, racism. But I didn't want to debate that fact so much as understand how she thought about it. Although people commented on it, Yelena didn't think too much about the color of her skin when she was a child. She didn't feel different because she was Black, but because her family came from America. It wasn't until she started thinking about boys and love that she thought more and more about the way she looked, how much she stood out from everyone else.
我认为无知可以是，而且通常就是种族主义。但我不想辩论那个事实，而是想理解她是怎样看待这件事的。尽管人们对此发表评论，但叶莲娜在童年时期并没有过多考虑自己的肤色。她感到不同并不是因为她是黑人，而是因为她的家庭来自美国。直到她开始考虑男孩和爱，她才越来越多地思考自己的长相，思考自己与其他人有多么不同。
And I would ask my mother, Mom, why am I so ugly? Why is my nose so big? Why are my lips so huge? And she would say, no, you're beautiful. And then she would ask her American friends to bring American magazines, Black and Lovely-- I think it was called Black and Lovely. And my mom would show me those magazines and say, look, those beautiful women, you look just like them.
我会问我母亲，妈，为什么我这么丑？为什么我的鼻子这么大？为什么我的嘴唇这么厚？她会说，不，你是美丽的。然后她会让她的美国朋友带来美国杂志，《黑人与美丽》——我想它是叫这个名字。我妈妈会向我展示那些杂志并说，看，那些美丽的女人，你看起来就像她们一样。
And I would take this. I was so proud, I would take this magazine, bring it to Sasha and other friends in the street and say, look, I'm just like them. And they would say, Yelena, this is a very strange magazine. Why is everybody Black in it? Don't bring those magazines anymore. And I felt so lonely, because I didn't have anybody just like me.
我会接受这个。我非常骄傲，我会拿着这本杂志，带给萨沙和街上的其他朋友，说，看，我和她们一样。他们会说，叶莲娜，这真是一本很奇怪的杂志。为什么每个人都是黑人？别再带那些杂志来了。我感到如此孤独，因为我身边没有和我一模一样的人。
I had assumed that there would be a little community of all the Black Russians, that they'd stick together and hang out all the time. But it sounds like Yelena didn't have that, wasn't around people that looked like her, not even her mom, really. Lily was much lighter and gorgeous, according to Yelena.
我曾以为会有一个由所有黑人俄罗斯人组成的小社区，他们会团结在一起并一直在一起玩。但听起来叶莲娜没有那样，她身边没有长得像她的人，甚至连她妈妈都不是。据叶莲娜说，莉莉皮肤要白得多，也非常漂亮。
Just for the record, when I met Yelena, I thought she was gorgeous. There's something regal about her. It's hard to imagine her as a self-conscious teenager, but she was.
郑重声明，当我见到叶莲娜时，我觉得她很漂亮。她身上有一种高贵的气质。很难想象她曾是一个缺乏自信的青少年，但她确实是。
My mother would always remind me. Let's say she would tell me, be careful with boys. They would not date you because they love you, but because they would want to try dating a Black girl. And that's why my self-esteem was damaged, probably, because I didn't trust any Russian guy that would approach me. And I didn't believe that somebody would fall in love with me at all, sincerely.
我母亲总是提醒我。比方说，她会告诉我，对男孩要小心。他们和你约会不是因为爱你，而是因为他们想尝试和一个黑人女孩约会。这就是为什么我的自尊心受到了损害，可能吧，因为我不相信任何接近我的俄罗斯男人。我根本不相信有人会真诚地爱上我。
I wanted to know the ways in which being Black shaped Yelena's life in Russia. And to hear her tell it, her family was never denied an apartment because of their race. She was never put into an inferior school because of her race. She was never singled out by law enforcement because of her race. There wasn't that kind of institutional racism.
我想知道身为黑人在俄罗斯对叶莲娜的生活产生了怎样的影响。按照她的说法，她的家庭从未因为种族而被拒绝租住公寓。她从未因为种族而被送入劣质学校。她从未因为种族而被执法部门针对。没有那种制度性的种族主义。
But she was lonely. She felt undesirable. Being Black made it hard for her to imagine a future with a partner. So much of my conversation with her was about wanting to find her person, her strong desire to find someone, and her fear that she wouldn't.
但她很孤独。她感到自己不受欢迎。身为黑人让她很难想象与伴侣的未来。我和她的大部分谈话都是关于想要找到属于自己的人，她找到某人的强烈愿望，以及她害怕自己找不到的恐惧。
Despite her insecurities, Yelena was popular and accomplished. She took music lessons, spoke perfect English, and was an excellent tennis player, just as her grandfather would have wanted. Her mother constantly reminded her that she had to be better than everyone else. Apparently, you still have to be twice as good in the Soviet Union.
尽管有这些不安全感，叶莲娜还是很受欢迎并取得了成就。她上音乐课，说一口流利的英语，是一名出色的网球运动员，正如她祖父所希望的那样。她母亲不断提醒她，她必须比任何人都优秀。显然，在苏联，你仍然需要付出两倍的努力。
She was recruited to play tennis at one of the country's top universities and accepted into their prestigious journalism program. She had so much going for her, but she still felt like no boy would ever want to date her, until she met Vaisa.
她被招募到该国顶尖大学之一打网球，并被他们负有盛名的新闻专业录取。她前途无量，但她仍然觉得没有男孩会想和她约会，直到她遇到了瓦伊萨。
He was a chess champion. And well, I started in Moscow State University, so I was a tennis player. He was a chess player. And (LAUGHING) we were a beautiful couple.
他是国际象棋冠军。嗯，我开始在莫斯科国立大学，所以我是一名网球运动员。他是国际象棋选手。而且（笑）我们是一对美丽的夫妇。
And he had a very rough time dating me. Then the coach, physical training coach of the university, called his parents and said, do you know that he's dating a Black girl? And they said, well, yes. Why? What's wrong? And he said, because she will get pregnant, and she will marry him.
和他和我约会过得很艰难。然后教练，大学的体育教练，给他的父母打了电话，说，你知道他正在和一个黑人女孩约会吗？他们说，嗯，是的。为什么？有什么问题吗？他说，因为她会怀孕，然后她会嫁给他。
Then his parents called my mother and said, if you think that your daughter will make our son marry your daughter, you are wrong. And then my mom said, if you think that my daughter will marry your son, you're damn wrong. There's no way my gorgeous daughter will marry your ugly son. And it was just going back and forth, back and forth.
然后他的父母给我的母亲打电话说，如果你认为你的女儿会让我们儿子娶你的女儿，那你就错了。然后我妈说，如果你认为我的女儿会嫁给你的儿子，那你就大错特错了。我美丽的女儿绝不可能嫁给你丑陋的儿子。就这样来来回回。
So he felt that he had to demonstrate that, no matter what, he will be with me. So he started missing his classes. And he would come to my classes and sit there. So the teachers from his classes would write him, you have to attend. You have to attend. Boom, boom, boom. So the end of the story was very sad. He was kicked out of university for missing classes, and he was taken to the army.
所以他觉得他必须证明，无论如何，他都会和我在一起。于是他开始旷课。他会来到我的课堂坐在那里。所以他课程的老师会写信给他，你必须出席。你必须出席。砰，砰，砰。所以故事的结局非常悲惨。他被大学开除了，因为旷课，然后被送去参军了。
Wait, he had to go to the army?
等等，他不得不去参军？
Yeah, yeah. If you are kicked out of university, you have to go to the army.
是的，是的。如果你被大学开除，你就必须去参军。
Wow.
哇。
So that was my first experience dating a Russian boy.
所以那就是我第一次和俄罗斯男孩约会。
Yeah-- a pretty dramatic end to a first relationship. But the drama didn't stop there for Yelena. A few years later, she dated a Russian guy from Veronezh, a small town about a day's drive away from Moscow. They went to visit his parents and stay for the weekend. One morning, she came back from the shower and caught her boyfriend's mother examining the bed sheets.
是的——第一次恋情的结局相当戏剧性。但对于叶莲娜来说，戏剧性并没有就此停止。几年后，她和一个来自沃罗涅日的俄罗斯男人约会，那是一个离莫斯科开车一天距离的小镇。他们去探望他的父母，并在那里住了一个周末。一天早上，她洗完澡回来，抓到男朋友的母亲在检查床单。
And later, I asked my boyfriend, what was she looking? And he said, well, she never saw people of color, so she thought that the sheets would be turned to-- and she was very surprised that they were clean.
后来，我问我男朋友，她在找什么？他说，嗯，她从来没见过有色人种，所以她以为床单会变成——她非常惊讶它们是干净的。
But again, it was not racism, it was pure ignorance-- pure ignorance. And this woman adored me later. So but I felt that enough is enough, and it's time for me to be with people that knows who I am, that don't look at my sheets, and don't ask stupid questions.
但再一次，那不是种族主义，那是纯粹的无知——纯粹的无知。这个女人后来非常喜爱我。所以我感觉已经受够了，是时候让我和那些知道我是谁的人在一起了，他们不会看我的床单，也不会问愚蠢的问题。
Something was missing for Yelena in Russia. And like me and her grandparents, she decided to look elsewhere for answers. She thought she'd find them in the very country that her grandparents had fled-- America. Yelena had heard about American racism, but she still thought she would be better off in the USA.
在俄罗斯，叶莲娜缺少了一些东西。像我和她的祖父母一样，她决定去别处寻找答案。她以为她能在她祖父母逃离的那个国家——美国找到答案。叶莲娜听说过美国的种族主义，但她仍然认为在美国会过得更好。
When we saw Eddie Murphy, when we heard about Arthur Ash, when we heard about those brilliant musicians and jazz musicians, and all of them were Black and very, very, very successful. So when my grandmother would start telling me about racism, I would say, yeah, yeah, yeah, right, and think about all those very famous African-American athletes that would be laughing all the way to the bank. So I felt that I would be understood much better by people like me. And in fact, yes, I was dreaming about going to United States and marrying an African-American.
当我们看到艾迪·墨菲，当我们听说阿瑟·阿什，当我们听说那些才华横溢的音乐家和爵士乐手时，他们所有人都是黑人，并且非常、非常、非常成功。所以当我的祖母开始向我讲述种族主义时，我会说，是啊，是啊，是啊，对，想想那些非常有名的非裔美国运动员，他们会笑着赚大钱。所以我感觉那些像我一样的人会更好地理解我。事实上，是的，我梦想着去美国并嫁给一个非裔美国人。
When you pictured and dreamed of going to America, what did that life look like?
当你想象并梦想去美国时，那样的生活是什么样子的？
How would this guy look like? The man of my dream?
这个家伙会是什么样子？我梦想中的男人？
[LAUGHS] I said life, but I guess we could also get a description of the guy.
[笑] 我说的是生活，但我猜我们也可以得到对那个家伙的描述。
Uh, yeah. See, I was not really dreaming about skyscrapers and, you know, capitalism, and all that. I didn't understand about that, but I just felt that-- what's this song? (SINGING) One day, da da da dum, he'll be tall and Black. Da da da dum. Whose song was that?
呃，是的。你看，我并不是真的在梦想摩天大楼，你知道，资本主义，所有这些。我不了解那些，但我只是觉得——这首歌是什么？（唱歌）有一天，达达达，他会又高又黑。达达达。那是谁的歌？
"One Day Your Prince Will Come," The Sleeping Beauty.
“有一天你的王子会来”，《睡美人》。
Yeah. Yes.
是的。是的。
Actually, "It's The Man I Love." It's Gershwin, not Disney. But what do I know? My parents almost exclusively listened to Stevie Wonder's Inner Visions for most of my childhood.
其实是“我爱的那个男人”。是格什温的作品，不是迪士尼的。但我懂什么呢？在我童年的大部分时间里，我父母几乎只听史蒂夫·旺达的《内在愿景》。
I was expecting to meet a prince that would look like me. And he would look at me and he would say, oh, my God, you're so gorgeous. Because even the guy that really, really loved me, Vaisa, in the university, he used to call me Monkey. He called me Monkey, with love. He didn't realize that that was insulting.
我期待着遇到一位看起来像我的王子。他会看着我说，噢，天哪，你是如此美丽。因为即使是那个真心、真心爱我的男人，瓦伊萨，在大学里，他曾叫我“猴子”。他叫我猴子，是带着爱意。他没有意识到那是在侮辱人。
And I never told him that, in America, that would be insulting. But you know, in Russia, guys would call their girls Rabbit-- I don't know-- my cat. Well, he called me, My Monkey. And I couldn't explain to him that that was racist, because I knew he was not a racist. That's just how he called me. And I felt, OK, if I look like a monkey, and so what?
我从来没有告诉过他，在美国，那会是侮辱。但你知道，在俄罗斯，男人们会管他们的女孩叫“兔子”——我不知道——“我的小猫”。好吧，他叫我“我的猴子”。我无法向他解释那带有种族主义色彩，因为我知道他不是种族主义者。他就是那么叫我。我觉得，好的，如果我看起来像猴子，那又怎样？
Wait. So this guy called you Monkey, and you didn't say, hey, you can't do that?
等等。所以这个家伙叫你猴子，而你没有说，嘿，你不能那样做？
But he didn't insult me. He didn't mean to insult me, he loved me. And as I told you, he was punished for this love. [CHUCKLES]
但他并没有侮辱我。他不是想侮辱我，他爱我。而且正如我告诉你的，他因为这份爱受到了惩罚。[轻笑]
I would have trouble with that one. [CHUCKLES]
如果是我，我会觉得这很麻烦。[轻笑]
I know. I know. I know it sounds terrible to you. I know.
我知道。我知道。我知道在你听来这很糟糕。我知道。
Yelena moved to America in 1989. She was 27 years old, and she built a life for herself there. She worked as a journalist. She made friends, Black friends. She loved to go to Black churches and listen to gospel music live. She went to salons that actually knew how to style Black hair. And she found her Black Prince Charming.
叶莲娜于1989年移居美国。她当时27岁，在那里为自己建立了一段生活。她做过记者。她交了朋友，黑人朋友。她喜欢去黑人教堂，现场听福音音乐。她去了真正懂得如何打理黑人发型的沙龙。并且她找到了她的黑人白马王子。
He was perfect. He was perfect. He was playing tennis. He loved jazz. He liked classical music. He was just perfect for me.
他是完美的。他是完美的。他打网球。他爱爵士乐。他喜欢古典音乐。他对我来说简直是完美的。
They dated for a few years. Yelena was sure he was going to propose. And then one night, he invited her out to a fancy restaurant.
他们约会了几年。叶莲娜确信他会求婚。然后有一天晚上，他邀请她去一家高档餐厅。
So I got dressed. I prepared. I knew how I will answer him. So we go to this restaurant, very fancy restaurant. And the reception, they tell us that, we are sorry, it is packed. But there is just one place near the bathroom.
所以我穿戴整齐。我准备好了。我知道我会怎么回答他。所以我们去了这家餐厅，非常高档的餐厅。前台告诉我们，对不起，这里客满了。但厕所旁边还有一个位置。
And he says, no, no, no, we're not taking it. And I said, no? Why not? He says, well, I want to sit near the window. I said, well, it doesn't really matter-- window, bathroom. I mean, it's clean. The food is the same. Because I wanted to hear the proposal, OK? I didn't care where we were sitting.
他说，不，不，不，我们不去那儿。我说，不？为什么不呢？他说，嗯，我想坐在窗边。我说，嗯，其实没关系——窗边，厕所。我是说，那是干净的。食物是一样的。因为我想听到求婚，好吗？我不在乎我们坐在哪里。
Fair. Yes. Yeah.
有道理。是的。是啊。
So he said, no. And he said, Yelena, you don't understand. Our grandparents were fighting, they were dying for the right to sit at the window, not at the bathroom. And I said, you know, in Russia, unless you bribe, you won't get a table, regardless of your color. As long as you're green, you will get it. So please stop feeling so insecure.
所以他说，不。他说，叶莲娜，你不明白。我们的祖父母在战斗，他们为坐在窗边而不是厕所边的权利而牺牲。我说，你知道，在俄罗斯，除非你贿赂，否则你拿不到位子，不管你的肤色如何。只要你是“绿色的”（有钱），你就能拿到。所以请停止感到如此自卑吧。
And he said, you know what? We would never understand each other. You're Black outside, but you're white inside. You don't understand what we went through. And that was the end of our proposal.
他说，你知道吗？我们永远不会理解彼此。你是外黑内白。你不明白我们经历了什么。这就是我们求婚的终结。
Was that the end of your relationship?
那是你们关系的终点吗？
Yes. Yes, yes, because it showed that we were so different. And he said that we would never understand each other.
是的。是的，是的，因为它显示了我们是如此不同。他说我们永远不会理解彼此。
She agreed. They had different pain points. In Russia, she hadn't experienced the kind of institutional racism he had. And she said her boyfriend couldn't possibly feel the things that upset her as a Russian the way she felt them.
她同意了。他们有不同的痛点。在俄罗斯，她没有经历过他所经历的那种制度性种族主义。她说她的男朋友不可能像她那样感觉到那些让她这个俄罗斯人感到不安的事情。
Do you feel like you fully understand African-American-- the sort of pain points? Or no?
你觉得你完全理解非裔美国人……那种痛点吗？或者没有？
I understand them, but I don't feel them. That's the difference. The things that upsets, let's say, African-Americans, I can see why that upsets, but it doesn't hurt.
我理解它们，但我感觉不到它们。这就是区别。比方说，那些让非裔美国人感到不安的事情，我能看出为什么这会让他们不安，但这并不会伤害我。
When he said to you, you're Black on the outside, but you're white on the inside, what was your reaction to that?
当他对你说，“你是外黑内白”时，你对那有什么反应？
I thought he was stupid. I said, how could I be Black and white inside? I mean, I am who I am. And the things that I went through, you don't understand.
我觉得他很愚蠢。我说，我怎么可能是外黑内白？我是谁就是谁。而且我经历的事情，你不理解。
Did you guys ever talk about race before the argument that you had in the restaurant? Was that a conversation you guys had, or not at all?
你们在餐厅发生争论之前谈论过种族问题吗？那是你们谈论过的话题，还是根本没有？
No, he-- no, we didn't talk about that. No.
没有，他——没有，我们没谈过那个。没有。
Did it surprise you when it came up in the restaurant?
当它在餐厅里提出来时，你感到惊讶吗？
Yes, it did, because I still don't believe that if they didn't offer us a place near the window, it meant that it was racism. I still don't believe so.
是的，感到惊讶，因为我仍然不相信如果他们没有给我们一个窗边的位子，就意味着那是种族主义。我仍然不相信。
So for you, it feels easier just to sort of give a little bit of the benefit of the doubt, or be like, I can't know for sure what the intention was, so I have to let it go.
所以对你来说，给别人一点怀疑的好处似乎更容易，或者像，“我无法确定意图是什么，所以我必须放手。”
Yes, I don't know for sure, and I don't want to think about it. I don't want to damage my nerve system by thinking about that. I will never know the truth, number one. Number two, it can be both. Number two, it can be both. And number three, what difference does it make?
是的，我不确定，我也不想去想它。我不想通过思考那种事情来损害我的神经系统。第一，我永远不会知道真相。第二，它可能是两者兼而有之。它可能是两者。第三，那又有什么区别呢？
It's so interesting that you say that, just because I feel like it's a thing we do all the time in America is that we replay out these moments of discomfort for each other in the Black community over, and over, and over again.
你说那件事真有趣，只是因为我觉得在美国我们一直在做的一件事就是，我们不断地在黑人社区里一遍又一遍地重演这些让我们不舒服的时刻。
What for? What for? What are you gaining? If you told me that I did that and, as a result, this restaurant was closed, for example, or as a result, this waiter was kicked out, that makes sense. But why going through that again, and again, and again, without any results? Why scratching the place until the first blood on your body?
为什么？为什么？你获得了什么？如果你告诉我我那样做了，结果，比如，这家餐厅关闭了，或者结果，那个服务员被开除了，那说得通。但为什么在没有任何结果的情况下一遍又一遍地经历那个？为什么一直抓挠那个地方直到身上流血？
But I think part of the reason we do it is to recognize that this is happening. Like, we must acknowledge that this is happening. We can't pretend it's not happening.
但我认为我们这样做的部分原因是认识到这种情况正在发生。我们必须承认这种情况正在发生。我们不能假装它没发生。
Yes, I acknowledge it. But again, if I would sit down at home and start, oh, they did it because I'm Jewish, no, they did it because I'm Black. No, they did it because my grandparents are American. No, they did it because of that, and that, and that. You know, there's no end to that.
是的，我承认。但再一次，如果我坐在家里开始想，“哦，他们这样做是因为我是犹太人，不，他们这样做是因为我是黑人。不，他们这样做是因为我的祖父母是美国人。”你知道，那没完没了。
I think for many Black Americans, there's a curiosity, a need to understand and explore that constant unease we experience. Because I'm Black, is my doctor giving me proper care? Because I'm Black, am I here to fill a diversity quota? Because I'm Black, am I being pulled over? Part of what it means to be Black here, part of what draws us together is investigation of that discomfort. There's communal reassurance in that.
我认为对于许多非裔美国人来说，有一种好奇心，一种理解和探索我们所经历的持续不安的需求。因为我是黑人，我的医生是否在给我提供适当的照顾？因为我是黑人，我是不是为了凑多样性指标而在这里的？因为我是黑人，我是不是正被拦下？在美国身为黑人的部分意义，部分吸引我们走到一起的东西，就是对那种不适感的调查。那里面有社区的慰藉。
I know that Black people are not a monolith. Yet, the fact that Yelena didn't have this curiosity surprised me. But it also made sense. Yelena didn't have an echo chamber of injustices growing up.
我知道黑人不是一个同质的群体。然而，叶莲娜没有这种好奇心的事实让我感到惊讶。但这也有道理。叶莲娜在成长过程中没有遭遇不公的共鸣。
I can talk to my hairstylist, my trainer, my family, and say, hey, this thing happened. Yelena had no community to share with, nobody to co-sign. Her problems were not those of Black people, but her own.
我可以和我的发型师、我的教练、我的家人交谈，说，嘿，发生了这种事。叶莲娜没有社区可以分享，没有人可以认同。她的问题不是黑人的问题，而是她自己的问题。
I want to be clear. Being Black is not some joyless exercise for me. I wouldn't trade it for the world. I'm not moping about. But Yelena's right about one thing-- thinking about race all the time is exhausting. But I can't let it go, and I tried to explain to her why.
我想说明一下。身为黑人对我来说不是什么毫无乐趣的练习。我不会为了世界上的任何东西而改变它。我不是在郁郁寡欢。但叶莲娜关于一件事是对的——一直想着种族问题让人筋疲力尽。但我无法放手，我试图向她解释原因。
I feel like part of it is like, there are small things that I feel like, in some ways, add up to one really big problem that just still hasn't been solved. That it's like, it's small things that add up to feeling like you don't belong here, that the country that you've always existed in doesn't want you. And I don't know. I feel--
我觉得部分原因是，有些小事加起来形成了一个尚未解决的重大问题。就像，有些小事让你感觉你不属于这里，你一直存在其中的国家并不想要你。我不知道。我觉得——
See, I had this dream that, yes, somewhere there was another world where I belonged to. And this is America. Now with you, I don't understand where your dream house is.
你看，我曾做过这个梦，是的，在某个地方有另一个我属于的世界。那就是美国。现在和你在一起，我不明白你的梦想之家在哪里。
I don't know where my dream house is. I don't know exactly where this place is.
我不知道我的梦想之家在哪里。我不知道这个地方究竟在哪里。
Back to Africa, right? Are you talking about going to Africa? I don't think so.
回到非洲，对吧？你在说去非洲吗？我不这么认为。
I don't even think it's necessarily back to Africa. I think I don't know if this place exists. I think it's just this place, in some ways, still doesn't accept me after all of this time, and that maybe this is as good as it gets, and maybe there isn't another place or a better option. Do you think it's silly that I think about these things so much?
我甚至不认为一定是回到非洲。我觉得我不知道这个地方是否存在。我认为它只是这个地方，在某些方面，过了这么久仍然不接受我，也许这就是最好的结局了，也许没有另一个地方或更好的选择。你认为我思考这些事情这么多很傻吗？
Yes. I think it's silly that you think about it so much. There are more important things in your life, that you don't have to waste your time on things that you cannot change. And you don't have to change those people. If that's how they are, I don't think you have to waste your life on changing them. You just drop them and go on with your life.
是的。我认为你想这些想得太多了很傻。你生活中还有更重要的事情，你不必把时间浪费在那些你无法改变的事情上。你也不必去改变那些人。如果他们就是那样，我不认为你必须浪费生命去改变他们。你只需要放下他们，继续你的生活。
Don't worry about the things you cannot change. Sometimes, I think Yelena's right, that I'm silly for obsessing over this stuff. And I wonder if maybe she's better off for not having spent her entire life puzzling and picking over every interaction with white people, that maybe her grandparents moving to the USSR helped her bypass parts of America's particular brand of racism.
不要担心你无法改变的事情。有时，我想叶莲娜是对的，我为这些事情着迷很傻。我想知道也许她因为没有花一辈子去琢磨和深究每一次与白人的互动而过得更好，也许她祖父母搬到苏联帮助她绕过了美国特有的种族主义品牌。
But maybe I never really had a choice. Race, specifically Black and white, is such an integral part of living in this country. Yelena insists I have bigger things to worry about. But honestly, I can't think of anything that affects me more. Being a Black American is what keeps me from feeling like I truly belong in this country.
但也许我从来没有选择的余地。种族，特别是黑人和白人，是生活在这个国家的一个组成部分。叶莲娜坚持认为我有更重要的事情要担心。但老实说，我想不出还有什么比这更能影响我了。身为一个美国黑人是我感觉不到自己真正属于这个国家的根本原因。
Have you ever felt like you belonged somewhere? Have you ever found that place?
你有没有觉得你属于某个地方？你有没有找到那个地方？
You know what? For me, it's not where, it's more with whom. That's what was important for me when I lived in the United States. It was important that I was surrounded by people I really loved. It doesn't matter where I am. As long as I'm surrounded by love, that's all that matters.
你知道吗？对我来说，不是在哪里，而是和谁在一起。当我在美国生活时，那对我来说很重要。重要的是我身边围绕着我真正爱的人。我在哪里并不重要。只要我身边围绕着爱，那就是最重要的。
I wish that surrounding myself with people I love solved my problem. I am surrounded by people I love. A lot of those people are Black. And as long as I feel threatened on behalf of all of them, I can't stop wishing there was a better place for us.
我希望身边围绕着我爱的人能解决我的问题。我身边确实围绕着我爱的人。这些人中有许多是黑人。只要我因为他们所有人而感到受威胁，我就无法停止希望有一个更好的地方给我们。
Yelena's better place turned out to be right where she started. She lived in the USA for 12 years and might have stayed, but then she met her husband-- a white Russian man. And they moved to Moscow where he did treat her like a princess. It was hard to find a Black salon in Moscow back then, so he would fly her to Paris just to get her hair done.
叶莲娜更好的地方原来就在她开始的地方。她在美国住了12年，可能本来会留下，但她遇到了她的丈夫——一位俄罗斯白人男性。他们搬到了莫斯科，在那里他确实把她当作公主对待。当时在莫斯科很难找到黑人沙龙，所以他会带她飞往巴黎，只是为了让她做头发。
Emanuele Berry is one of the producers of our show. Thanks to Yelena Demikovsky, who's making a documentary about Black Russians that includes Yelena Khanga. Coming up, a guy gets kicked out of a thing he had no idea he could get kicked out of. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
伊曼纽尔·贝里是我们节目的制作人之一。感谢叶莲娜·德米科夫斯基，她正在制作一部关于俄罗斯黑人的纪录片，其中包含了叶莲娜·汉加。接下来，一个家伙被赶出了一个他根本不知道会被赶出的东西。那是芝加哥公共广播电台在我们的节目继续时的一分钟。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, Get Back to Where You Once Belonged, stories of people who do not feel quite at home where they are, searching for their place and their people. We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, Nowhere Man.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目《回到你曾经属于的地方》，讲述那些在他们所在的地方并不真正感到宾至如归，寻找他们的地方和他们的人的故事。我们已经到达了节目的第二幕。第二幕，《无处之人》。
So this story is about somebody who felt like he really had found his place in the world-- a job he was good at, a group of people that he liked and admired. And then he got kicked out, and kicked out in this way he didn't even know was a possibility. Reporter Jeremy Raff explains.
这个故事是关于一个觉得自己真正找到了世界位置的人——一份他擅长的工作，一群他喜欢和钦佩的人。然后他被赶走了，以一种他甚至不知道有可能的方式被赶走了。记者杰里米·拉夫解释说。
Raul Rodriguez is like a lot of the dads I grew up with in Texas, but somehow even more so. He fixes his own truck, kills his own goats. And when you walk into his living room, there's two buck heads on the wall, a big TV, and in the middle of it all, the thing he's most proud of, on a little shelf encased in plexiglass.
劳尔·罗德里格斯就像我在德克萨斯州一起长大的许多父亲一样，但不知何故更是那样。他修理自己的卡车，屠宰自己的山羊。当你走进他的客厅时，墙上有两个鹿头，一台大电视，而在所有这一切的中间，他最引以为傲的东西，在一个有机玻璃展示柜的小架子上。
This is my Department of Justice badge or the Immigration Inspector badge that was--
这是我的司法部徽章或移民检查员徽章，曾经是——
It's kind of surprising that Raul ended up working for immigration, given how he first met those guys. He grew up in Mission, Texas, right by the border. He'd go back and forth between Mexico and the US all the time.
劳尔最终为移民局工作有点令人惊讶，考虑到他第一次见到那些家伙的情景。他在德克萨斯州的米申长大，就在边境旁边。他一直往返于墨西哥和美国。
And when he crossed, the border agents would always stop him, bust his chops, ask for his papers. He'd always show them-- here's my birth certificate, born in Brownsville, Texas. But they were jerks about it. By the time Raul was a teenager, he says it was like a ritual.
当他过境时，边境特工总是拦住他，找他麻烦，要求他出示证件。他总是给他们看——这是我的出生证明，出生于德克萨斯州的布朗斯维尔。但他们对此表现得很粗鲁。当劳尔十几岁时，他说那就像一种仪式。
The officer usually kind of looks at you and then starts saying, OK, what's your name? Says, you know why we're bringing you in here? And I go, yeah, pretty much. He wanted to know if I'm a citizen or not. And I says, well, I am. And he says, well, we know you're not. And I says, OK, well, show me. Oh, you know, we can't show you.
警官通常会盯着你看，然后开始说，好的，你叫什么名字？他说，你知道我们为什么要把你带到这里吗？我说，是的，几乎知道。他想知道我是不是公民。我说，嗯，我是。他说，嗯，我们知道你不是。我说，好的，那你证明给我看。哦，你知道，我们不能证明给你看。
And I tell him, come on, man. I've been here many times, and it's not right for you to harass me like this. I don't know why, because I don't look the part. I don't look as US citizen-y enough as you want me to. My features are very Hispanic, very Mexican.
我告诉他，拜托，伙计。我来过这里很多次了，你不应该这样骚扰我。我不知道为什么，因为我看起来不像。我看起来不够像你们想要的美国公民。我的特征非常西班牙裔，非常墨西哥。
Eventually, after a bit, they'd let him go, every time.
最终，过了一会儿，他们每次都会放他走。
He was going back and forth across the border so much because his parents were in Mexico, and he lived with his aunt and uncle in Texas. It wasn't a great situation. His cousins never really accepted him. They beat him up. At family functions, his aunt and uncle would introduce their own kids first, then him. He says he was an afterthought at best.
他之所以频繁往返边境，是因为他的父母在墨西哥，而他和他的姑姑、姑父住在德克萨斯州。那并不是一个好的情况。他的表兄弟姐妹从来没有真正接受过他。他们殴打他。在家庭聚会上，他的姑姑和姑父会先介绍他们自己的孩子，然后是他。他说他顶多是一个事后考虑的对象。
I got called from bastard to a Negro, because I was different from their color. I was very dark, compared to them. They were very light-skinned. And I don't know what the translation would be, a arrimado. Do you know what I'm talking about? Arrimado, that word, arrimado, it's a relative that just stays there, like a leech.
我被叫作杂种甚至黑鬼，因为我和他们的肤色不同。和他们相比，我非常黑。他们的肤色很浅。我不知道翻译会是什么，arrimado。你知道我在说什么吗？Arrimado，这个词，arrimado，就是一个住在那里，就像水蛭一样的亲戚。
When Raul would visit his parents during the summers, he'd beg to stay. He hated living in Texas, but they always sent him back. Your mom gave birth to you on the US side so you could be a citizen, they'd say. It's going to be better for you there. Trust us.
当劳尔夏天去看望他的父母时，他会乞求留下。他讨厌住在德克萨斯州，但他们总是把他送回来。你妈在美国那边生下你，这样你就能成为公民，他们会说。在那边对你会更好。相信我们。
Eventually, Raul says, it did get better. After high school when he joined the Navy, the structure, the order, the authority, he liked it, which led him to law enforcement. After the Navy, he became an immigration officer, just like the officers who harassed him when he was a teenager. He even got assigned to the same bridge he used to cross back then. Some of the very same officers who doubted his citizenship were now his co-workers.
最终，劳尔说，确实变好了。高中毕业后，当他加入海军时，那种结构、秩序、权威，他很喜欢，这引导他走进了执法部门。海军退役后，他成为了一名移民官员，就像他十几岁时骚扰他的那些官员一样。他甚至被分配到了他曾经往返的那座大桥上。一些曾经怀疑他公民身份的官员现在成了他的同事。
I had this one inspector that's a female. And when I showed up for work for the first day, I told her, remember me? She says, no, I don't remember you. Oh, you used to take me inside, and you wanted to break me. And she says, was I mean? I go, yes, you were very mean-- tried to intimidate me a lot. And oh, I'm sorry.
我有个检查员是女性。当我第一天上班时，我告诉她，还记得我吗？她说，不，我不记得你了。噢，你曾经把我带进去，想摧毁我。她说，我当时很刻薄吗？我说，是的，你非常刻薄——试图恐吓我很多次。哦，对不起。
From the beginning, Raul was a very thorough officer. For example, one day this guy comes through who Raul knows really well. He used to work with him in a furniture factory. The guy was like an uncle to him. He's coming from Mexico into the United States. Raul checks his papers, and it turns out the guy had a tourist visa, which doesn't let you work. Raul revoked the visa-- took it away, didn't let the guy in.
从一开始，劳尔就是一名非常彻底的官员。例如，有一天一个家伙经过，劳尔很了解他。他曾经和他一起在家具厂工作。那个人对他来说就像一个叔叔。他从墨西哥来到美国。劳尔检查了他的证件，结果发现那家伙持有旅游签证，不允许工作。劳尔撤销了签证——收回了它，没让他进来。
For a while at one point, they called me El Gacho.
有一段时间，他们叫我“El Gacho”。
Kind of like "pain in the ass".
有点像“讨厌的家伙”。
Because I wouldn't let anything through. I had to do it. I didn't let anybody slack.
因为我什么都不放行。我必须这样做。我不让任何人偷懒。
Raul wasn't just thorough. His wife told me, there are a lot of slugs in federal government. Raul wasn't one of them. He's an above and beyond guy, a standout. And he stood out more and more, because it's pretty well documented Customs and Border Protection, or CBP, had some ugly instances of corruption, bribery, drug smugglers infiltrating.
劳尔不仅仅是彻底。他的妻子告诉我，联邦政府里有很多混日子的人。劳尔不是其中之一。他是一个超越自我的人，一个杰出的人。他越来越突出，因为有据可查的是，美国海关及边境保卫局（CBP）有一些丑陋的腐败、贿赂、毒贩渗透的案例。
By contrast, Raul was a total Boy Scout. He even won an award. In 2006, a woman approached him while he was buying cigarettes at the gas station. She asked him if he would look the other way while she smuggled in a kid and pushed a little piece of paper in his hand with her number on it. Raul set up a sting. And the next time they met, he wore a wire. She was later arrested.
相比之下，劳尔完全是一个童子军。他甚至赢得了一个奖项。2006年，一个女人在他加油站买烟时接近他。她问他是否愿意在走私一个孩子时睁一只眼闭一只眼，并往他手里塞了一张写着她电话号码的小纸条。劳尔设了一个圈套。下一次见面时，他带了窃听器。她后来被捕了。
CBP gave Raul its integrity award, one of their highest honors. His bosses flew him to Washington for a big ceremony. Raul got to wear his finest uniform. His kids were there. They got to see him walk across the stage and shake the commissioner's hand. And they gave him a plaque, which these days sits in a place of honor, near the deer heads in his living room.
CBP授予了劳尔诚信奖，这是他们最高的荣誉之一。他的老板送他去华盛顿参加了一个大型仪式。劳尔穿上了他最好的制服。他的孩子们也在那里。他们看着他走上台，和专员握手。他们给了他一块牌匾，这些天它被放在客厅里，靠近鹿头的显眼位置。
And in his personal life, too, he was totally by the book. He was taught not to fraternize with anyone breaking immigration laws. It could cost you your job.
在私生活中，他也完全按规矩办事。他被教导不要与任何违反移民法的人交往。这可能会让你丢掉工作。
So you have to cut ties with anybody that's had that kind of a history. Well, everybody has people who are illegally in the US, so you have to cut those out.
所以你必须切断与任何有那种历史的人的关系。嗯，每个人都有非法在美国的人，所以你必须把那些人切断。
Anyone he was close to who was undocumented, he cut out of his life-- friends, family members. Raul didn't make exceptions.
他亲近的任何非法移民，他都从生活中切断了——朋友、家庭成员。劳尔没有例外。
Raul found his home-- customs. It's actually remarkable how much Raul refers to the people he worked with as family, as a brotherhood.
劳尔找到了他的家——海关。劳尔将他共事的人称为家人、兄弟会，这实际上令人瞩目。
I finally belonged to somebody, to belong to something. And it feels good to be wanted, to be accepted, when you never did when you were an outcast, or when you were just there.
我终于属于某个人，属于某样东西。当你从未被接受，或者仅仅是作为一个局外人时，被人需要、被接受的感觉真好。
They did all the things families do-- a combination of responsibilities, but also fun. They threw barbecues. They went to baptisms, birthday parties. They hung out all the time. Then one day in April, 2018, Raul goes into work. He's starting his shift.
他们做了家人所做的一切事情——职责的结合，也有乐趣。他们举行烧烤。他们去参加洗礼、生日派对。他们一直在一起玩。然后2018年4月的一天，劳尔去上班。他开始轮班。
And I see the two managers come in. I says, oh, man, there comes the two chiefs. Everybody, be careful. Make sure you're not on the phones, and stuff like that. They go into the office. They set up, I guess. And I'm doing my work and stuff. And one of them comes out and says, hey, Raulito, and come to the office.
我看见两位经理进来了。我说，噢，天哪，那两个主管来了。每个人，小心点。确保不要玩手机，之类的东西。他们进了办公室。他们准备好了，我猜。我在做我的工作之类的事情。其中一个出来说，嘿，劳尔，来办公室。
Raul had no clue what this was about, but it looked serious.
劳尔根本不知道这是关于什么的，但这看起来很严重。
They never called you just for nothing. And they don't come in twos just for nothing. They have to have a witness. They open up an envelope, and that's where it says-- it says we're going to have to pick up your gun, your weapon, and your credentials. The paper says you're no longer, as of this date, a law enforcement officer, until pending further investigation.
他们绝不会无缘无故地叫你。他们也不会无缘无故地两人一起进来。他们必须有一个证人。他们打开一个信封，上面写着——它说我们要收回你的枪、你的武器和你的证件。文件说，自即日起，你不再是执法人员，直到有进一步的调查。
You know, investigation? What for? I've never done anything wrong. He says, we don't know nothing about that. He says, we're just giving you the notice and here to pick up your weapon and your badge. And so I take off my belt. I give them my belt. And I take off my badge. And I take out my credentials, and I gave it to them.
你知道，调查？为什么？我从未做过任何错事。他说，我们对那点一无所知。他说，我们只是给你通知，来拿你的武器和徽章。所以我摘下我的腰带。我把腰带给他们。我摘下我的徽章。我拿出我的证件，给他们了。
Raul's head was spinning. He'd worked there for 18 years. He was close to retirement. Had he done something illegal and not known about it? Something small he'd forgotten about? He scanned his memory, and he couldn't think of a single thing. Raul walked back out into the main office. Everyone was looking at him, kind of sideways.
劳尔脑子里乱成一团。他在那里工作了18年。他快退休了。他做过什么违法的事而自己不知道吗？一些他忘记了的小事？他扫描了自己的记忆，却想不出任何一件事。劳尔走回主办公室。每个人都在斜眼看他。
I was embarrassed, because I had to do that walk of shame, walk amongst my fellow officers without a badge and a gun. And people were just looking at me, saying, hey, what's wrong? What's wrong? I said, I don't know, man. I don't know.
我很尴尬，因为我不得不经历那种耻辱的行走，在我的同事中间走过，没有徽章和枪。人们只是看着我说，嘿，怎么了？怎么了？我说，我不知道，伙计。我不知道。
He sat at his desk for a minute, and then he called his wife. She works at another branch of Homeland Security. He was quietly freaking out, so he went home. He and his wife went around and around, trying to think of what it might be. For the life of them, they had no clue.
他在办公桌前坐了一会儿，然后给妻子打了电话。她在国土安全部的另一个分支工作。他当时在悄悄地发疯，所以他回家了。他和妻子反复思量，想知道这可能是关于什么的。他们绞尽脑汁，也毫无头绪。
About a week later, the OIG, the Office of Inspector General, wanted to meet with me at the courthouse building. They take us into a room, one of those typical cop rooms that has the small table. And it has the dark window, where you know that they're watching you from the other side.
大约一周后，监察长办公室（OIG）想在法院大楼和我见面。他们把我们带进了一个房间，那些典型的小桌子的警察审讯室之一。它有暗窗，你知道他们在另一边盯着你。
So agents come in, and they read me my rights. So I said, OK, this is criminal. And so he says, are you familiar with this piece of paper? And they slide it over to me.
特工进来了，他们宣读了我的权利。我说，好的，这是刑事案件。他说，你熟悉这张纸吗？他们把它推给我。
From his 18 years as a customs officer, he could tell right away what it was-- a Mexican birth certificate.
从他作为海关官员的18年经验，他立刻就能看出那是什么——一张墨西哥出生证明。
I just didn't know whose it was, until I actually read it. So I started reading. I see my name, Raul Rodriguez. And I see my parents' names, Francisca, Margarito, and my grandparents' names--
我只是不知道那是谁的，直到我真的读了它。所以我开始读。我看到了我的名字，劳尔·罗德里格斯。我看到了我父母的名字，弗朗西斯卡、玛格丽托，还有我祖父母的名字——
Do you recognize it? I go, I've never seen it, but I know that it's mine because it's got my name, my parents' names, and my grandparents' names. But I don't recognize the date of birth. That's a different one from the one I have now.
你认识它吗？我说，我从未见过，但我知道它是我的，因为它有我的名字、我父母的名字和我祖父母的名字。但我对出生日期没有印象。那和我现在用的那个不一样。
On this birth certificate, not only was his birthday different, but more importantly so is his place of birth-- a village outside of Matamoros, Mexico. If this thing was real, then Raul was not American. Raul was confused. He had his birth certificate from Brownsville, Texas. He'd been using it his whole life. It didn't make sense.
在这张出生证明上，不仅他的生日不同，更重要的是出生地也不同——墨西哥马塔莫罗斯外的一个村庄。如果这东西是真的，那么劳尔就不是美国人。劳尔很困惑。他有他在德克萨斯州布朗斯维尔的出生证明。他一生都在使用它。这说不通。
The agents explained. Raul had applied for a green card for his brother. As part of the application process, they'd looked into Raul's own citizenship documents. And in their research, they'd stumbled onto this, this Mexican birth certificate. And here they were.
特工们解释了。劳尔曾为他的兄弟申请绿卡。作为申请过程的一部分，他们调查了劳尔自己的公民身份文件。在研究过程中，他们偶然发现了这个，这个墨西哥出生证明。然后他们就在这里了。
Raul was like, look, this is not the first time someone's scrutinized my citizenship. We'll get to the bottom of it and clear it up. He told the agents, you know what? Let me get my dad in here. Right then and there, he called his nephew and got him to drive his dad over the border.
劳尔说，看，这不是第一次有人审查我的公民身份。我们会查个水落石出，澄清这一切。他告诉特工，你知道吗？让我把我爸带到这里来。就在那时那刻，他给侄子打了电话，让他开车把爸爸从边境带过来。
They all met just a few hours later at a Starbucks. Raul sat with his father and the two investigators at a table inside. No one ordered coffee. Raul's dad, Margarito, told the investigators the story that Raul had always heard, that Raul's mom crossed the border so he'd be born in Brownsville.
几小时后，他们都在星巴克见面了。劳尔和他的父亲以及两名调查员坐在里面的桌子旁。没人点咖啡。劳尔的父亲玛格丽托告诉调查员劳尔一直听到的那个故事，说劳尔的母亲越过边境，所以他是在布朗斯维尔出生的。
Then the investigators showed him the Mexican birth certificate. Margarito looked down at the table. He admitted that, yes, Raul was born in Mexico, at home. Yes, his birth date was in 1968, not 1969. Yes, Raul was a Mexican citizen.
然后调查员向他展示了那张墨西哥出生证明。玛格丽托看着桌子。他承认，是的，劳尔确实是在墨西哥家里出生的。是的，他的出生日期是1968年，不是1969年。是的，劳尔是墨西哥公民。
He had been texting me during the day.
他白天一直在给我发短信。
That's Raul's wife, Anita. Because Anita also works in immigration, she knew how serious this all was.
那是劳尔的妻子安妮塔。因为安妮塔也在移民局工作，她知道这一切有多严重。
He texted me back a message that indicated that it was regarding his birth. So I said, well, where are you? And he told me where he was. And I said, OK, I'm on my way.
他回了我一条信息，暗示那是关于他的出生。所以我说，你在哪？他告诉我他在哪。我说，好的，我正在赶去。
She rushed over to the Starbucks.
她冲了过去。
And when I got to the location, him and his dad were walking out. They were both crying. And I heard my father-in-law, suegro, telling him, "Lo siento mijo, lo hice por tu bien." I'm sorry, son. I did it for your benefit. And I just-- my heart sank.
当我到达那个地方时，他和他的父亲正走出来。他们都在哭。我听到我的公公在对他说：“Lo siento mijo, lo hice por tu bien.” 对不起，孩子，我是为了你好。我感觉心沉了下去。
And I feel bad now, because I literally unloaded on my father-in-law. I told him off. And of course, Dad just says, we did it because we thought it was best for you, to give you a better opportunity.
我现在感觉很糟糕，因为我真的向我公公发火了。我训斥了他。当然，爸爸只是说，我们这样做是因为我们认为这对你是最好的，为了给你一个更好的机会。
And he has had a great opportunity. If it wasn't for what they did, I wouldn't have him, and I wouldn't have my kids. I'm thankful for that. But at any point, they could have said, wait, I need to tell you this. And they never did.
他也确实得到了一个很好的机会。如果不是因为他们所做的一切，我就不会有他，我也不会有我的孩子。我很感激这一点。但在任何时候，他们都可以说，等一下，我需要告诉你这件事。但他们从来没有说。
Raul's sister saw it differently. They don't blame their dad, Margarito. They tried to convince Raul that what their father did was forgivable, even understandable. Back then, unauthorized border crossings were an unremarkable fact of life. The border fence, the agents, surveillance blimps, that all came later, especially after 9/11.
劳尔的姐姐看法不同。他们不责怪他们的父亲玛格丽托。他们试图说服劳尔，父亲所做的是可以原谅的，甚至是情有可原的。那时，未经授权的边境穿越是生活中一件平常事。边境围栏、特工、监视飞艇，那都是后来才有的，特别是在9/11之后。
Margarito told me he regrets getting the fraudulent birth certificate now. He prides himself on being honest. And he said he's ashamed to face Raul, but it didn't seem like such a serious offense at the time. It's hard to get exact numbers, but one investigation in the 1990s found 900 fraudulent birth certificates registered by midwives in South Texas, same as Raul's.
玛格丽托告诉我，他现在很后悔获取虚假的出生证明。他以诚实为荣。他说他很羞愧面对劳尔，但在当时这看起来并不像是什么严重的违法行为。很难获得准确的数字，但20世纪90年代的一项调查发现，德克萨斯州南部的助产士登记了900份虚假出生证明，和劳尔的一样。
The undoing of Raul's citizenship set off a chain reaction in his family. Raul's son, who he'd had from a previous marriage, had gotten his citizenship through Raul. Here's Anita again.
劳尔公民身份的撤销在他家庭中引发了连锁反应。劳尔从上一段婚姻中生下的儿子，通过劳尔获得了公民身份。安妮塔接着说。
What happens to him? What happens to my daughter-in-law and my grandkids if he gets deported? But people aren't thinking about that. You know, it's that ripple effect.
如果他被驱逐出境，他会怎样？我的儿媳和孙子会怎样？但人们没在想那个。你知道，那就是连锁反应。
Raul broke the news to his son, Raul Jr., that afternoon after he left the Starbucks. He explained the whole thing. Raul's citizenship was no longer valid, so neither was Raul Jr.'s. Now they were both undocumented.
那天下午离开星巴克后，劳尔告诉了儿子小劳尔这个消息。他解释了整件事。劳尔的公民身份不再有效，所以小劳尔的也不再有效。现在他们都是非法移民。
Incredibly, Raul Jr. Had just applied to become a CBP officer himself. His interview was coming up in a couple of weeks. Now, of course, that wasn't going to happen.
令人难以置信的是，小劳尔本人刚刚申请成为一名CBP官员。他的面试几周后就要进行了。现在，当然，那不会发生了。
Raul's lawyer told me that when someone like Raul signs up to serve in the government, like by joining the military, or working for CBP, the government doesn't look too hard for reasons why they can't. It's when the person asks for something in return, like a green card for a brother, that the government takes a closer look.
劳尔的律师告诉我，当像劳尔这样的人报名为政府服务时，比如加入军队或在CBP工作，政府不会太费力去寻找他们不能加入的原因。只有当此人要求回报时，比如为兄弟申请绿卡，政府才会更仔细地审视。
After that day at Starbucks, Raul and Anita immediately made a plan for how to fix all of this. Raul could just apply for a green card, because his wife is a citizen. It would be a hassle, but they would get through it. So they filled out the application. And Raul, in his Raul way, was super upfront about everything. He knew what he was up against.
在星巴克那天之后，劳尔和安妮塔立即制定了如何修复这一切的计划。劳尔本可以申请绿卡，因为他的妻子是公民。这会很麻烦，但他们会挺过去的。所以他们填好了申请表。劳尔，以他那种劳尔的方式，对一切都超级坦诚。他知道他面对的是什么。
He'd made a false claim to US citizenship, said he was an American when he really wasn't. But there's a clause in the US immigration code that says if he didn't do it knowingly, the government can exercise discretion. He and Anita were hoping that USCIS, the agency that issues green cards, would see this all as a big mix-up, granting the exception, and they would be done.
他曾对美国公民身份提出过虚假声明，说他是美国人，而他实际上并不是。但美国移民法中有一条条款说，如果他不是故意这样做的，政府可以行使自由裁量权。他和安妮塔希望USCIS，签发绿卡的机构，能把这一切看作是一场大误会，给予例外，然后他们就没事了。
They thought it would happen quickly, actually, which wasn't the case. For a long time, they didn't hear anything-- so long they started to get nervous. They started to look for help from public officials. After all, Raul is a veteran law enforcement. They reached out to their congressman, then Ted Cruz, the senator. That's not the full list.
他们以为这会很快发生，其实不然。很长一段时间，他们没有任何消息——长到他们开始感到紧张。他们开始寻求公职人员的帮助。毕竟，劳尔是一位资深的执法人员。他们联系了他们的国会议员，然后是参议员泰德·克鲁兹。那不是完整的名单。
I told him the other day. I said, you know what? I said, we both voted for Trump. Why don't we call him and say, hey, help me out, pres. I voted for you. And I said, ah, no, better not. He might come down and deport you. And then where would we be? Even at the AOC, the Ocasio-Cortez, I sent her a message before we contacted you. She never responded.
我前几天告诉他。我说，你知道吗？我说，我们都投票给了特朗普。我们为什么不给他打电话说，嘿，帮帮我，总统。我投票给了你。我说，啊，不，最好别。他可能会下来把你驱逐出境。那我们会怎样？即使是AOC，奥卡西奥-科尔特斯，我在联系你之前也给她发过信息。她从未回复。
Everywhere they looked, people were turning their backs. That thing about how customs officers aren't supposed to hang out with undocumented people, that was Raul now. So all his friends, the co-workers he referred to as family, they almost all abandoned him. In theory, his wife Anita shouldn't even be hanging out with him. One person who did reach out to him-- that lady who used to bust his chops in the bridge when he was a kid. Raul explained to my producer, Nadia Reiman.
他们到处寻找，人们都在背过身去。关于海关官员不应该和非法移民在一起的那件事，那现在就是劳尔的情况。所以他所有的朋友，那些他称为家人的同事，他们几乎都抛弃了他。按理论，他的妻子安妮塔甚至不应该和他在一起。唯一一个联系他的人——那个在他十几岁时在大桥上找他麻烦的女士。劳尔向我的制作人纳迪亚·雷曼解释说。
She thought I was having financial troubles, and so she called me up, and she offered to give me money.
她以为我有财务困难，所以她打电话给我，提出要给我钱。
But she didn't say anything to you about, like, you know, your citizenship or anything like that?
但她没对你说任何关于，你知道，你的公民身份或类似的事情吗？
No, I told her. I told her, I guess you were right.
没有，我告诉她了。我告诉她，我想你是对的。
What did she say?
她说什么了？
She just started laughing. She says, ah, Raul, don't say that.
她只是开始笑。她说，啊，劳尔，别那么说。
Another friend who stood by Raul and still sees him is John A. Garcia, the Jag. It's his initials. They met for breakfast at a Mexican place across the street from an immigration detention center for kids.
另一个支持劳尔并仍然见他的朋友是约翰·A·加西亚，也就是“Jag”。那是他名字的首字母。他们在移民拘留中心街对面的一家墨西哥餐厅吃了早餐。
The Jag is allowed to see Raul, because he's retired. He left customs last year. He said it was too stressful. He wanted something more relaxed, so he became a drill sergeant at a boot camp for kids who get in trouble. They gossip about work, who got a promotion, about that guy with the dog breath.
Jag被允许见劳尔，因为他退休了。他去年离开了海关。他说压力太大了。他想要一些更轻松的工作，所以他成为了一名专门处理麻烦少年的训练营的教官。他们闲聊工作，谁升职了，关于那个有口臭的家伙。
About his hygiene en la boca.
关于他嘴里的卫生。
And the Jag's encounter with that woman in the cargo lane.
还有Jag在货运通道遇到那个女人的事。
You remember la flaquita? In Los Indios?
你记得那个瘦子吗？在洛斯因迪奥斯？
Gloria?
格洛丽亚？
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
She slapped me.
她打了我一巴掌。
Oh, she did. Nhombre.
噢，她打了。没天理。
Yeah. Ooh, she just lit up the freaking dynamite, man. I was coming back.
是的。噢，她点燃了那该死的炸药，伙计。我正回来。
So much drama. Eventually, after about 40 minutes, they finally start talking about Raul's situation, about how he's afraid to even leave the house.
太多戏剧性了。最终，大约40分钟后，他们终于开始谈论劳尔的情况，关于他甚至害怕离开房子。
Like right now, I don't have any status at all. I can get stopped right now, and I can get deported, pretty much, or set up for deportation. It's on my side, se ve un poquito mas. It's a little bit more difficult to deal with because, if I get stopped by Border Patrol right now, I'm a goner. I have no status. So right now, can I really go out? I go out, but I'm looking over my shoulder.
就像现在，我根本没有任何身份。我现在可能被拦下，然后我可能会被驱逐，基本上，或者被设定为驱逐。在我这边，看起来更困难一些，因为，如果我现在被边境巡逻队拦下，我就完蛋了。我没有任何身份。所以现在，我真的能出去吗？我出去，但我一直在看我的肩膀。
You're like all these other people.
你和其他人一样。
[BLEEP]
[消音]
You're in the same boat, you know?
你在同一条船上，你知道吗？
Exactly.
正是。
Raul tells the Jag he's been waiting way too long for an answer on his green card. He's starting to get really frustrated. He feels like the government's singling him out because he was a customs officer.
劳尔告诉Jag他等待绿卡答案的时间太长了。他开始感到非常沮丧。他觉得政府因为他曾是海关官员而针对他。
He thinks they're trying to cover up that they employed an undocumented immigrant by mistake for so long. He says this over and over. He said it to me lots of times. But the Jag's not sure he's right. He says, maybe the government wants to show they don't give anyone preferential treatment.
他认为他们正试图掩盖他们长期以来错误雇佣了一名非法移民的事实。他一遍又一遍地说这个。他对我说了好多次。但Jag不确定他是对的。他说，也许政府想表明他们没有给任何人优惠待遇。
Unfortunately, if it ever comes out, they're probably going to have to show that, hey, well, we gave him what he deserved like everybody else, you know? What if he breaks the law? We're going to give him an exception. Everybody is going to say, wait a minute. You can't do that.
不幸的是，如果这事一旦曝光，他们可能不得不表明，嘿，好吧，我们像其他人一样给了他他应得的待遇，你知道？如果他违法了呢？我们要给他例外。每个人都会说，等一下。你不能那样做。
The Jag does try to make Raul feel better. He tells him he's sure he'll get US citizenship, eventually. He asked Raul if he's talking to his dad. He isn't. The Jag says he should.
Jag确实试图让劳尔感觉好一点。他告诉他，他确信最终会获得美国公民身份。他问劳尔是否在和他父亲交谈。他没有。Jag说他应该。
But ultimately, what leaves an impression on me is that he talks about Raul's case like any other, like an unfortunate undocumented person. Raul sits there, taking it all in, but looking like he doesn't really agree.
但最终，给我留下深刻印象的是，他谈论劳尔的案子就像谈论任何其他案子一样，就像一个不幸的非法移民。劳尔坐在那里，接受这一切，但看起来他并不真的同意。
Raul and Anita had been waiting for nine months when they finally got called in for the green card interview. Anita said it was a jarring experience. These were officers like the guys they both worked with, who were the first ones to jump in when things got tough. They'd had each other's backs for years. If anyone would get that Raul had done nothing wrong, it would be them. But that's not what happened.
劳尔和安妮塔等了九个月，终于接到绿卡面试的电话。安妮塔说那是一种令人震惊的经历。这些都是像他们曾经共事过的同事那样的官员，当情况变糟时，他们是第一批冲上去的人。他们多年来一直互挺。如果有人会理解劳尔什么都没做错，那一定是他们。但事实并非如此。
We were treated like criminals. They took a sworn statement from each of us. They took two from him, like they were trying to trip him up, or trip me up, or something. And I don't blame the specific officers that did the interview. You do what you're told. If I didn't need my federal job, I would have told them all to go to hell.
我们被当作罪犯对待。他们从我们每个人那里拿到了宣誓书。他们从他那里拿了两份，好像他们试图把他绊住，或者把我绊住，或者是别的什么。我不责怪进行面试的具体官员。你做你被要求做的事。如果我不需要我的联邦工作，我会让他们都去见鬼。
It's about as dramatic a reversal as you could imagine. Raul was a hard ass, rule following law enforcement officer who'd learned he'd been violating the very rules he'd been enforcing for almost 20 years. Did it change him? Did he see things differently? Did the rules seem fair, now that he's on the receiving end of them?
这简直是你所能想象的最戏剧性的逆转。劳尔曾经是一名死板的、遵守规则的执法人员，他发现自己近20年来一直在违反自己所执行的规则。这改变了他吗？他看事情的角度不同了吗？现在既然自己是规则的接收端，规则看起来公平吗？
We talked about this a lot. Raul says the cases he's thinking about now are the ones where he stuck to the rules and didn't give people a break. And as a result, they suffered, badly. Like there's this one case, a brother and a sister, they were both really young.
我们谈论过很多次。劳尔说他现在考虑的案子是他坚持规则没有给别人机会的那些。结果，他们遭受了严重的痛苦。就像有一个案子，一对兄弟姐妹，他们都非常年轻。
They were being smuggled. We had to call the consulate and arrange transportation back to their home countries. It turns out that this little boy, he was coming to donate an organ to his sister, who was dying in Houston. He was going to donate one of his kidneys, and we couldn't even let him through to save this little girl's life.
他们被走私。我们不得不给领事馆打电话，安排送回他们的祖国。结果证明，这个小男孩，他是来为在休斯敦垂死的姐姐捐献器官的。他要捐献一个肾脏，我们甚至不能让他通过来救这个小女孩的命。
And the little boy was like, man, I gotta go. I have to go. And they said, no, he can't. And we had to turn him back. He starts crying, and crying, and crying. And, what's wrong? Hey, what's going on? Why are you crying? He said, I left my Bible over there. We'll just give you another one. He said, no, no, that's my Bible. [EMOTIONAL] Oh, man. [CRYING]
那个小男孩就像，伙计，我得走。我必须走。他们说，不，他不能。我们不得不让他回去。他开始哭，哭，哭。怎么了？嘿，怎么回事？你为什么哭？他说，我把圣经落在那边了。我们只是给他另一本。他说，不，不，那是我的圣经。[情绪激动] 噢，伙计。[哭泣]
At this point in the interview, Raul got out of his chair, got some water from the kitchen.
在面试的这个阶段，劳尔从椅子上站起来，去厨房拿了些水。
I'm sorry, man.
抱歉，伙计。
Take your time. Take your time.
慢慢来。慢慢来。
Oh, man, just-- man, I haven't cried in a long time, dude.
噢，伙计，只是——伙计，我很久没哭了，伙计。
You're good.
你很好。
Anyway, I just had to turn him over. And now I did, I feel like [BLEEP]. He was doing it for a good reason. He was doing something-- he felt he was doing something good, and then he was being treated like a-- like that. You know?
不管怎样，我不得不把他送走。现在我做了，我觉得像[消音]。他这样做是有充分理由的。他是在做某事——他觉得他在做某件好事，然后他被当作——那样的对待。你知道吗？
This is a story he's always felt bad about. But it feels worse now, I think, in part because he can relate to the kid a little more, to someone trying to do the right thing caught on the wrong side of the rules. It's also a story where following the rules makes you do a thing that also feels very wrong.
这是一个他一直感觉不好的故事。但我觉得现在更糟了，部分原因是他更能理解那个孩子一点，因为有人试图做正确的事却站在了规则的错误一边。这也是一个遵循规则让你做一件同时也感觉非常错误的事情的故事。
You placed a lot of faith in the rules.
你对规则投入了太多的信仰。
Yeah.
是的。
Because when you did these difficult things that you had to do-- deport a teen or turn back this organ donor child-- it was sort of like, essentially, the rules are the rules. I can't do anything about it. And now that you're on the receiving end of that, do the rules seem more arbitrary to you, or meaningless, than they used to?
因为当你做这些你必须做的困难事情时——驱逐一个青少年或送回这个器官捐献者孩子——这有点像，本质上，规则就是规则。我对此无能为力。现在既然你在那边的接收端，这些规则对你来说看起来比以前更武断，或者更没有意义了吗？
No, they don't. I still believe that the rules are the rules. They still apply, and I have to abide by them. I still have to follow the rules, regardless of what the outcome is or what happens. And that's the frustrating part, is that they've gone overboard on my case, on my situation. They're doing things differently with me, because of who I am.
不，并没有。我仍然相信规则就是规则。它们仍然适用，我必须遵守它们。我仍然必须遵循规则，无论结果如何或发生了什么。那才是最令人沮丧的部分，是他们把我的案子、我的情况做得过火了。他们因为我是谁，对我做的事情不同。
USCIS won't comment on ongoing cases. But I ran this by four immigration lawyers, and they said everyone is being treated badly. They didn't think Raul was being treated worse than anyone else.
USCIS不会对正在进行的案件发表评论。但我把这告诉了四位移民律师，他们说每个人都受到了糟糕的待遇。他们不认为劳尔比别人受到的待遇更糟。
One in Texas, who has a lot of experience in this exact kind of case said, sure, two years ago, Raul would have gotten a green card. But since President Trump, basically everyone with fraudulent birth certificates is denied. In fact, if anything, she said, he's lucky they didn't lock him up or put him into deportation proceedings.
德克萨斯州的一位在处理这类案件方面有很多经验的律师说，当然，两年前，劳尔会拿到绿卡。但自从特朗普总统以来，基本上每个持有虚假出生证明的人都被拒绝了。事实上，如果说有什么的话，她说，他很幸运他们没有把他关起来或让他进入驱逐程序。
There's lots of ways this is hard for Raul. His wife, Anita, she told me she thinks a lot about how Raul never wanted to grow up in Texas with his aunt and uncle and cousins, how, if he'd had it his way, he would have stayed in Mexico with his mom and dad working on the farm. In the end, somehow the choices his dad made deprived Raul of a home on either side of the border.
这对劳尔来说有很多困难的方式。他的妻子安妮塔告诉我，她经常想劳尔从来不想在德克萨斯州和他的姑姑、姑父和表兄弟姐妹一起长大，如果他按自己的方式，他本可以留在墨西哥和他的妈妈、爸爸在农场工作。最终，不知何故，他父亲的选择剥夺了劳尔在边境两侧的家。
All those years that my husband was here growing up with his aunt and uncle, suffering without his mom and dad-- when he'd miss his mom, he'd always tell me, I wish I had been born in Mexico, because then I could have stayed with my mom and dad. And now at the age of 50, he finds out that he could have had that. And they lied to him this entire time. It's like, now what? Was it because they didn't want me?
这么多年来我丈夫在这里和他的姑姑、姑父一起长大，在没有妈妈和爸爸的情况下受苦——当他想念他妈妈时，他总是告诉我，我希望我是在墨西哥出生的，因为那样我就能和我的妈妈、爸爸在一起了。现在在50岁的时候，他发现他本可以有那个。而他们瞒了他这么长时间。这就像，现在怎么办？是因为他们不想要我吗？
Raul hasn't talked to his dad in months, since that day at the Starbucks.
自从星巴克那天以来，劳尔几个月没和爸爸说话了。
It totally changed how I see him now, to where I thought he was my hero. Even though I didn't grow up with him, I took him to heart. I strongly believed in what he told me and what he said. And one of the things was that, better be as honest as you can I don't know. I don't know if I'll ever see my dad again after this.
这完全改变了我现在看他的方式，我曾经以为他是我的英雄。尽管我不是和他一起长大的，但我记住了他。我强烈相信他告诉我的和他说的话。其中一件事是，最好尽量诚实。我不知道。我不知道在那之后我是否还会再见到我的爸爸。
Has he reached out?
他联系过吗？
No, not at all. I don't think I want to see him ever again.
没有，根本没有。我想我永远不想再见到他了。
Months tick by, then a year, with no decision by the government about Raul's green card application. Then on October 29th of last year, Raul got a letter from the government. His green card application was denied.
几个月过去了，又是一年，政府关于劳尔绿卡申请的决定没有任何消息。去年10月29日，劳尔收到了一封政府的信。他的绿卡申请被拒绝了。
They said Raul had made a false claim to US citizenship, said he was an American when he really wasn't. It also pointed out that he'd committed voter fraud by voting as an undocumented immigrant. Of course, Raul thought he was a citizen at the time. He thought voting was the right thing to do.
他们说劳尔对美国公民身份提出了虚假声明，说他是美国人，而他实际上并不是。它还指出他通过作为非法移民投票犯下了选民欺诈罪。当然，劳尔当时以为自己是公民。他以为投票是正确的事。
Raul's world has shrunk down to a few acres that he and Anita own. He keeps goats, cattle, a bunch of chickens. He watches the news in the morning while he walks on the treadmill. His badge and integrity award are still above the TV.
劳尔的世界缩小到了他和安妮塔拥有的几英亩土地。他养了山羊、牛、一群鸡。他在跑步机上走路时看早间新闻。他的徽章和诚信奖仍然在电视机上方。
He and Anita had dreamed of retiring in their 50s and driving around the country in an RV, maybe visiting their kids at college, or on a base if they decided to join the military. Now they can't leave town. There are Border Patrol checkpoints on all the major roads heading out of the valley.
他和安妮塔曾梦想在50多岁退休，开着房车环游全国，也许在他们上大学时去看看他们的孩子，或者如果他们决定参军的话去基地看看。现在他们不能离开城镇。在离开山谷的所有主要道路上都有边境巡逻检查站。
After a career of working double shifts and overnights, he finally has time to himself to think-- maybe too much. The stress of being undocumented is getting to him. He only sleeps for two or three hours at a time. He and Anita started fighting. Raul worried for a while they were headed for divorce.
在经历了一段双重轮班和夜班的职业生涯后，他终于有时间自己思考了——也许太多了。成为非法移民的压力正在压垮他。他一次只能睡两三个小时。他和安妮塔开始吵架。劳尔担心他们快要离婚了。
His lawyer told me that Raul could be in this limbo for three or four more years, before exhausting his appeals. Raul told me he's thought of just giving up and leaving. It would be drastic, but it would bring this to an end.
他的律师告诉我，劳尔可能在这种不确定状态中再待三四年，才能耗尽他的上诉。劳尔告诉我，他想过放弃和离开。这会很极端，但这会把这一切带到一个终点。
If the courts ultimately deny him a green card and he's ordered to leave the country, he told me he would go. He'd obey the law. He said, I'm going to practice what I preach. He'd move to Mexico.
如果法院最终拒绝他的绿卡，并下令让他离开这个国家，他告诉我他会走的。他会遵守法律。他说，我会践行我说的话。他会搬到墨西哥。
As a former border officer who'd arrested smugglers, confiscated loads of drugs, he's worried the cartels might come after him. They would still see him as a US Customs and Border Protection guy, the way he wishes everyone else would.
作为一名前曾逮捕过走私者、没收毒品的前边境官员，他很担心卡特尔可能会找上门来。他们仍然会把他视为美国海关及边境保卫局的家伙，正如他希望别人都会看他的那样。
Jeremy Raff is a reporter for The Atlantic. He also did a print version of this story and a short video documentary where you can see Raul and Anita. It's at The Atlantic website.
杰里米·拉夫是《大西洋月刊》的记者。他还做了这个故事的印刷版和一个简短的视频纪录片，在那里你可以看到劳尔和安妮塔。它在大西洋网站上。
[MUSIC - "WHERE SHOULD I GO (PERTSONA)" BY ANEGURIA]
[音乐 - ANEGURIA的《我该去哪里 (PERTSONA)》]
Well, our program was produced today by Lilly Sullivan. Our staff includes Bim Adewunmi, Elna Baker, Emanuele Berry, Susan Burton, Ben Calhoun, Sean Cole, Neil Drumming, Noor Gill, Damien Graves, Seth Lind, Miki Meek, Lina Misitzis, Stowe Nelson, Katehrine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Christopher Svetala, Matt Tierney, Nancy Updike, and Julie Whitaker. Our managing editor is Diane Wu. Our executive editor is David Kestenbaum.
好了，我们的节目今天由莉莉·沙利文制作。我们的团队包括比姆·阿德武米、埃尔娜·贝克、伊曼纽尔·贝里、苏珊·伯顿、本·卡尔霍恩、肖恩·科尔、尼尔·德拉明、努尔·吉尔、达米恩·格雷夫斯、塞思·林德、米基·米克、莉娜·米西齐斯、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、纳迪亚·雷曼、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼、南希·厄普代克和朱莉·惠特克。我们的主编是戴安·吴。我们的执行主编是大卫·克斯滕鲍姆。
Special thanks today to Tonya Medley, Jorge Just, Jaime Diez, Lisa Brodyaga, Jodi Goodwin, Dan Kowalski, Stephen Yale-Loeher, Rachel Rosenbloom, and Laura Bingham. Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our archive of nearly 700 shows for absolutely free. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
今天特别感谢唐雅·梅德利、豪尔赫·贾斯特、海梅·迪兹、丽莎·布罗迪亚加、乔迪·古德温、丹·科瓦尔斯基、斯蒂芬·耶鲁-勒赫、雷切尔·罗森布鲁姆和劳拉·宾汉姆。我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以完全免费收听我们近700集的节目存档。《美国生活》由公共广播交换机构PRX分发到公共广播电台。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. Everything he knows about management, he told me he learned from one of the actors in West Side Story.
一如既往感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。关于管理，他知道的一切都是他在《西区故事》的一位演员那里学到的。
He told me you take a bottle, you break the bottle, and with this, whatever is left, you just put in their face.
他告诉我，你拿一个瓶子，打破瓶子，然后用剩下的东西，直接戳在他们的脸上。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。